[Music]
on tuesday canadian prime minister
justin trudeau extended the current ban
on americans crossing into canada
through february 21st the prohibition
was put in place in march of last year
as a way to control the spread of the
pandemic
and the policy may have had an impact an
estimated seven percent of americans
have now been infected with the
coronavirus that compares with less than
two percent of canadians but the closure
has also taken a toll on the small towns
that rely on cross-border traffic
the situation is desperate from coast to
coast as anna warner reports
so we're looking into canada when lars
jacobson spots a truck
crossing the canadian border into the
united states
oh you might actually see a border
crossing here comes the truck he sees
unfairness kovit has stopped people from
coming in
but not trucks facilitating commerce the
truckers can go back and forth
because covet can't get them but an
individual it can
what this making sense
[Applause]
his package store in jake's landing
idaho is within spitting distance of
canada
and now may go out of business we're
open
our customers are totally stuck on the
other side of the border
our clients are canadians we love
canadians in normal times canadian
customers save
time and money by shipping their
packages to jake's small mart
on the u.s side but now shelves are
jam-packed
we're just trying to get them to the
rightful owners but we can't do it until
they come down and get them
the loads are still coming in but close
to
2000 packages waiting here for people to
pick up now
those people normally also support
jacobson's other businesses in this
three building village
by buying gas shopping and eating in the
restaurant
the hardships span the entire 5500 mile
border
from washington state where kovitt
canceled ferry service on the olympic
peninsula
caused a 64 million dollar loss and took
110
jobs to kalispell montana where
retailers saw a 94 percent decrease in
credit card spending by canadian
shoppers
to fort fairfield maine where a golf
club that spans both countries has been
cut off from most of its members
in between there are 100 border
checkpoints and countless small
towns and businesses it's imperative
that the border gets back open
that we see commerce going back and
forth in bonners ferry idaho
population 2500 dennis weed runs the
economic development council
unemployment here nearly doubled to 7
percent
after the border closed government money
did provide
some relief stimulus package has helped
but that's run out
now people are working less hours not
hiring to try to
keep their expenses down until we get
through it over in eureka montana dave
clark's
first and last chance bar sits 200 yards
from the border
first place to get a drink on the way
down last place to get a drink on the
way home
that's why it's called first and last
chance bar it's
also on its last leg in a state where
canadians typically spend more than 200
million dollars a year
my income's down 60 percent i hadn't had
the ppp loan
and there's two grants that the montana
gave us
i'd be completely out of reserves back
in idaho the packages keep
piling up yeah you guys have a good day
thank you and lars jacobson passes the
time
counting the customers he does have each
day five
five four three four five
wishing there were more for cbs this
morning saturday
i'm anna werner growing up in buffalo on
the border there just ten minutes
from getting into canada i know how
important that relationship is and
it stinks right now yeah tough for a lot
of people out there yeah